because at least I would arrive late and
trusted to the occasion instead of
pooping myself
and vomiting during a performance hey
everybody out there at sport Bible you
guessed it you can hear me but I'm
invisible because I'm John Cena and
that's what I do you can't see me but
you've submitted questions which I will
provide answers now it's the weirdest
thing that's ever happened to me during
a match this is a difficult question
because how do we find what's weird
the list is long and distinguished the
most embarrassing thing is I performed
while I do food poisoning for those of
you know the food person it's when
something doesn't agree with you here
and tries to run out of your body here
and here I happen not to be wearing my
patent denim shorts this was way back in
the days of before
believe it or not I was wearing
Halloween already
spandex trunks at the end of the contest
the orange turn into a very unflattering
autumn brown do you want to see me mama
another wrestle nightmare to be would
have your music play you're not ready to
go out but I'm much rather that late
trusted to be occasion instead of
proving myself and vomiting during a
performance as far as like the best
piece of abuse that anyone has ever
shouted there was a very iconic picture
of young lady not so happy holding up
two fingers one on each hand and it is
not this one is not this with me it was
not this one it was not this I found
this so humorous that someone can
develop such a angst
such hate just kind of won her to smile
right really close to her she waves her
high signs really close to me she could
have done this
which is the universal sign for I don't
like you there's even emoji for it well
there's also an emoji for the other one
but that's different story altogether
now if you look at the course of history
the life of John Cena runs an absolute
parallel with the life of Furman
misunderstood everybody thinks you're
one thing but really more to you than
that I got picked on a lot for how I
acted how I looked
just builds up myself both on the
outside inside just like further I'm the
Invisible Man no one can see me yes you
think you are looking at me but this is
a massive amount of technological and
financial resource creating a hologram
because I'm actually technically
invisible you can interpret that you
[ __ ] with someone just see with
someone say took a picture with John he
was a nice guy
so guys John Cena signing off and
closing my chapter the sport bottle hope
you enjoyed it if you didn't you'll
never see me again
[Music]
you